finally on i want to just ask you a  question um not  about your political opinions or  anything like that but obviously there  is a very critical situation going on  with russia and i just want to ask you  is it affecting you at all are you  thinking a lot about it  uh i would say indeed uh  i wouldn't say that the last thing i'm  thinking is the tournament actually yeah  but surely uh this uh  this whole situation is uh  pretty sad for me and uh  well  uh by the way uh  uh it's uh it's a holiday yeah like uh  like the day of uh  uh fatherland guardians uh if translated  you know  word by word and  yeah that's uh in this day i'd like i'd  like to wish  basically everyone  uh just try to  be sane  yep but uh yeah indeed uh  and it's uh it's it's it's very serious  yeah very understandable yeah but we  hope um you get to focus on chess over  the next few days we wish you the best  of luck in the semi-finals starting  tomorrow  thank you thanks for joining us